david do you think it's a problem
that people are making huge amounts of
money
from the development and manufacture of
coronavirus vaccines
listen i think that my view on this will
probably anger most people
other than like social democrats that
are exactly in my political space
i think there has to be a middle ground
on this now on the one hand
we as bernie sanders recently said we
can't allow these pharmaceutical
companies
to hold governments and and humans
hostage
when it comes to something like health
as i've said before
demand for health care services and
medications and vaccines is inelastic
what i mean by that is
i my appendectomy right up until the day
at which my appendix
swelled and became painful i don't care
what the price is for appendectomies i
don't want one i don't need one
and then all of a sudden when i require
an emergency appendectomy
they have me over a barrel i need an and
i
i must find a way to pay any price for
an appendectomy
because healthcare services and demand
is uh is
is completely inelastic so we need
health is what we would call a special
case it can't just be left to
um the the free market now on the other
hand
as i've said before as a social democrat
i don't need i'm fine with the market
dictating
what video game consoles get made and
who makes them and what they charge i'm
okay with that i'm fine with that
mobile phones i'm okay you know i don't
need the government involved in
regulating mobile phone
prices i think that the market and with
that as a consumer product it's
i'm fine with that assuming that
everybody's playing within a regulatory
framework and to some degree the the
smartest
best people we have are going to be more
likely to line up to do
things like developing a vaccine for the
virus quickly
uh if there is something there for them
now
many people will point to russia and say
well look at russia
russia developed the sputnik vaccine
basically as quickly as the modern
and pfizer vaccines were developed and
because they did they didn't even finish
testing it they they started using it
even more quickly
if you understand the authoritarian
nature
of russia you would realize that
although it did happen essentially as
quickly as pfizer and modern which we
will talk about
it wasn't just because out of the the
the good will
and desire it took place you're talking
about an authoritarian situation there
uh as we've been talking about for
decades at this point in time so i mean
listen the turkish couple in germany
that developed what is now called the
pfizer vaccine
they are now very wealthy they uh
invested time and money in developing
the vaccine and now
there is a payoff if there was
absolutely no payoff then would they do
it again
i mean maybe not and you look at pfizer
pfizer increased revenue
two percent after investing billions of
dollars
in r d in production on this vaccine
um is that bad i mean two percent yeah
it's a huge company it's a huge
amount of money you could apply the same
logic to
researchers of other vaccines uh
don't we want people entering the field
of science
and developing things that can be
life-saving
of course we need to ensure access of
course we need situations where things
are subsidized
of course bernie is right when he says
you know the the patenting
of these vaccines when it comes to
them being produced in other countries
we need to take control of this we can't
do it in a way where other countries are
prevented from making the vaccine of
course we need to do all those things
those things but at the same time we
want to incentivize people
to get into these fields if the belief
is the way you make a lot of money
is by you know i don't know becoming a
celebrity
or an athlete or a um
you know high-priced lawyer or a
consultant or whatever and then people
don't get into these fields of medical
research that we're all worse off so
i believe there has to be a middle
ground um maybe the government needs to
be involved in
in determining what are fair prices you
know all of these things have caveats
but
context is crucial and
when you say should it be possible for
pharmaceutical companies
to hold the world hostage charging
three hundred dollars per vaccine dose
no no that shouldn't be possible
should it be okay for people that are
developing life-saving technologies
to be rewarded in a way that's
commensurate with what they are doing
yeah to some degree that should be okay
and you know what if they make a ton of
money they should pay a lot of taxes
and all of the other economic policy
that we and bernie and others have been
talking about i think context is key
and there has to be a middle path here
um and
i'm curious to hear from you where you
fall on this issue
make sure you are a member at
joinpackman.com to get access to the
bonus show
otherwise i'll see you on monday
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over 26
000 five-star reviews and they stand
behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman